hey I'm Ryan and I'm David and we're
doing an instant trailer review of the
guardians of the galaxy full trailer
which is not the 15 second teaser
correctly saw this is like a big movie
I'm very excited I'm a huge fan of the
new line of comic books that they came
out in this movie
yeah Brian Michael Bendis is the writer
and it's really funny and it's really
really clever and it looks like the
movie is doing just that
yeah when they got James Gunn to direct
it I thought it was interesting I'm not
a huge fan of his other new pause for a
sec it sure I believe is an infinity gem
I don't really know but I'm gonna go out
and limb and say that is if if the
post-credits sequence in Iron Man 3 I
know is the word for Thor the dark world
is any indication it seems like the
infinity gems and Thanos will play a big
part in that movie and this will
probably be a huge kind of keystone for
Phase two yeah
so this is Chris Pratt as Jason quill
starworld star-lord and that's Djimon
Honsou and it's kind of cool the first I
would say 45 seconds of this trailer is
kind of a build-up to a punch line which
is right here yeah it's funny cuz we
don't know you know he's not as famous
as he wants to be but that's pretty cool
I feel like this movie might be a little
more meta than the other Marvel films um
and a lot of this from the descriptions
and the kind of leaked footage that came
out of this the comic-con teaser it's a
lot of it's kind of touching on the same
faces this is um Jhansi we build a
sponsor' I also I read on Twitter that
this is a lot of the same footage from
then this might was this the same
trailer from comic-con that's what I've
been reading know if it's the same one
yeah but there's Chelsea Riley and they
kind of do this rap sheet of every
member of the guardians yeah we've all
seen the promo picture where at all five
of them are lined up and now it's
kind of life Zoe Saldana is Gamora it
looks like they did it old school just
painted her dream I think such I'm a big
fan of although as far as her roles I
mean she was an avatar right yeah sharks
right often does not appear at well I
mean who or just looks like her yeah I
spent like she does a lot of outer space
movie she does she's in space a lot and
there we go rocky raccoon who is
supposed to be like the break the
breakthrough character of this movie
yeah I don't hear his voice James Gunn
has said that Rocket Raccoon is kind of
the heart of the story like that's where
it's all coming from we found out
recently that Bradley Cooper Bradley
Cooper's voice and then here we have
Groot but the Vin Diesel will do the
voice oh well kind of confirmed
confirmed well it's kind of confirmed
they said that he's gonna be in it
they're not exactly they've been a
little coy about it but I really like
the design of group there's been a few
different designs of crew throughout the
years in Marvel history and I really
like this one works for a movie and he's
like a plant
sir Spratt is gonna be huge yeah and
also this character is supposed to be
human of all the Guardians he's the only
human yeah and I think this is so funny
I love it's censored like because
obviously you can't show a middle finger
in a trailer but the same time it really
shows like this sort of outlaw sort of
boyish humor that this character has and
he's got headphones aw he's from Earth
you know I really like that and also
instead of Zune looks like you also it
really shows that this movie is gonna be
really heavy on comedy yeah that's even
the tone that they're showing with this
this music here - it's like it's not the
usual like all the Thor movies always
have a lot of like cinematic orchestra
playing and this is sort of a pop song
yeah and it also with they show us a lot
more spaceships than we've seen in it
hmm any other Marvel movie Marvel heroes
have never rode spaceships in a movie so
it kind of plays up that this might be
more of a space opera II kind of thing I
hope that they go to a lot of space
ports that looks a little bit like Star
Trek this darkness this is really cool
looks like they're in a everyone's in
this place it looks like they're in a
prison well they I guess they are
breaking out because they do get
arrested
yeah and rocket and Groot it's kind of
touched on upon this but rocket and
Groot are supposed to be like really
really tight like they kind of travel as
a pair and they kind of hook up the rest
of the garden
that shot as a group that looked a lot
like the Hulk shot yes I mean the way
the mouse is opening um this just shows
Chris Pratt got jacked for this movie
yeah if anyone knows him on Parks and
Rec he plays Andy who supposed to be
kind of a fat guy a little bit but you
guys she's punching us um and zero dark
thirty though Chris Pratt definitely
played like a cool military guy yeah so
now we have sexy shot Chris Pratt sexy
shop Zoe Saldana she's green yes he's
still sexy even when she's green and
then here's some more that space
fighting so cool
do you think they'll go they don't go to
ask argue they that's a quick shot I
believe that um that might be Karen
Gillan from Doctor Who
she shaved her head for this I'm not
sure exactly I'm not sure if her
character is blue
and that's stuff it needs to El Toro and
he was a lender that post-credits Deena
Thor the dark and that's this kind of
lair where he collects things and that's
where they kind of played into the
infinity gems
I just want to point out that shot
that's the first that's that star-lord
with his mask on and that shot looks
just bad I mean like I kind of get doubt
over it i this is the most excited I've
been for a Marvel movie in quite some
time
yeah I really didn't know much about
this and I was shocked that it was so
funny that the trailer was actually
really funny because the teaser didn't
really do that yeah and everybody who's
been involved in like talked about it
granted I know that there's celebrities
who have to kind of promote their movie
but the amount of excitement that's kind
of come out of the people involved in
this movie talking about it it seems
like everybody was really passionate and
really into what they were making and
again James Gunn while I'm not a huge
fan of his other movies a really
interesting choice for a movie like this
enough so that I'm excited about it yeah
I mean so far stylistically I love like
just this title here I love that font I
love the look I love the cinematography
the humor has been like give me I
laughed twice I when I saw this trailer
I watched it I like rewound and we
watched it again yeah I'm excited that
we don't have to wait a year for this
yeah coming out in a few months this and
Godzilla for me most anticipated of the
year
I'm really excited yeah let us know what
you think of the guardians of the galaxy
theatrical trailer by commenting below
until next time I'm Ryan and I'm David
thank you for watching